Harold Urey was a chemist like Gerard
Kuiper he also had to fight his way into
science you raise family was poor like
Kuiper's so he took a job teaching
grammar school in a mining camp in
Montana the parents of one of his
students urged him to find a way to get
to college Harold Urey took that advice
all the way to a Nobel Prize in
Chemistry by 1949 he was riding high a
distinguished professor at the
University of Chicago then and now one
of the world's great capitals of science
but when Yuri read his morning paper
something began to curdle inside him a
rising resentment first a pang at a
fellow scientist heightened celebrity
well that was normal then he got to the
part about the origin of the planets he
was offended than an astronomer was
making pronouncements about the chemical
nature of the solar system
that was his turf
scientists are human we're primates we
carry the same evolutionary baggage as
everyone else Piper and Yuri were two
alpha males who chose scientific
argument as their weapon of combat and
the two men fought over a single hostage
a young student when Carl Sagan was a
kid he lived here in a small apartment
in Brooklyn
[Music]
in the mid-1940s he made this drawing
filled with predictions that is now in
the US Library of Congress
[Music]
engine running
in an era where life here was in the
last seconds of its four billion year
captivity on earth he dreamed of going
to the planets and even to the stars
but he didn't want to just go in his
imagination he wanted to really go he
wanted to know what those worlds were
really like and he knew that the only
way to do that was to become a scientist
the boy would come under the wings of
the two warring Giants as much as they
hated each other he loved them both
together the three of them would tear
down the walls between the sciences and
the boy would tear down the tallest wall
the one between science and everyone
else
[Music]
you